Ashley: If I asked all of you to tell me the
first thing that comes to mind when I say
the word play, there'd probably be as many
answers as there are people in this audience.
For a topic that seems so familiar and universal,
it's oddly elusive and hard to nail down in
words. To some it may connote running around
outside in the sun, a childhood memory, a
favorite game, toy or gadget. The varieties
of play are vast and unique to age and culture.
In today's high tech world the proliferation
of wireless devices, alternate reality games
and social media have only further broadened
the landscape of play.
Tonight's talk is part of a larger series
called "Designing Play" which began in February,
and invites people of all ages to invent,
explore, tinker, adventure, and have fun.
Over the past few months, we've relied on
designers of all types, graphic, landscape,
and architecturally trained ones, to create
hands-on opportunities for our visitors to
play and problem solve. The result: unbridled
creativity and innovation that's given rise
to structures built from toothpicks and gumdrops,
portraits construed from various styles of
typeface, and landscape drawings that allow
the imagination to run wild.
I've been very excited for this evening's
talk, which is the culminating moment of this
series. Tonight's guest, Edith Ackermann,
is what I might call a play expert. Trained
as a developmental psychologist, she received
her Doctor of Developmental Psychology, two
Master's Degrees in Developmental and Clinical
Psychology, and a Bachelor of Experimental
Psychology, all from the University of Geneva,
Switzerland, and is currently a visiting scientist
at Massachusetts Institute of Technology,
School of Architecture. Her research had led
her to team up with partners such as MIT Media
Lab, The Lego Learning Institute, and the
Exploratory Museum in San Francisco, to help
shape the future of play and learning in the
digital world.
She comes from a lineage of thinkers and scientists
who have transformed the fields of child development
and education, including John Piaget, who
she studied and collaborated with, Maria Montessori,
Leva Gatski, and Seymour Papert, all of whom
strongly believed that learners construct
knowledge through play.
Ackermann explains the overall purpose of
her work as three-fold: to bring users back
into the design process, to imagine and design
activities, artifacts, and spaces that bring
about delight and foster personal and societal
growth, and to help innovative teams of researchers
and practitioners bring strategic research
design and a user centered design approach
to product development.
I'd like to quote Edith, who says there are
two lessons that she has learned through her
career in research. When it comes to learning
and creative uses of technologies, children
have more to teach adults than adults to children.
When it comes to innovating for others, don't
guess what they want or do what they say,
co- create what they and you will love once
it is there.
I'd like to welcome Edith Ackermann.
[applause]
Edith Ackermann: Thank you, Ashley, and thank
you for having me come to the Walker Arts
Center. I am coming more from the sciences
and I am moving towards the arts, so it's
a great pleasure for me to be able to talk
here at the Walker Arts Center. The title
of my talk is "Playful Inventions and Explorations,"
which I borrowed, actually, from a title of
an institute and the network that exists and
that grew out of work that had been done at
the MIT Media Lab to begin with, in the group
that was lead by Mitchel Reznick, Seymour
Papert, and other people. And then it grew
across the country and it included, educators,
researchers, artists, practitioners, politicians,
and the purpose was actually to engage children
in activities that are innovative, that are
playful. There is a whole evolution of this
work that is happening also here in Minneapolis,
in this science museum, and the Exploratorium,
where I had the chance to work quite a bit.
So, this evening, I would like to talk a little
bit about these relationships between play,
imagination, creativity, innovation, and design.
As Ashley said, there are as many definitions
of play as people in this room. And it has
been very difficult for me to prepare this
talk, because each time when you enter in
the domain you lose yourself, you get lost.
So, it's just my take on the question tonight,
and it keeps changing and I just want to,
in a way, almost introduce a discussion.
So, I will talk about children's learning,
children's play, play and creativity in children
and grown-ups, play for education, which is
a difficult topic, its like, "What could it
be?" The future of play in children, so-called
degenerates. And last but not least, if I
ever get there, is to think about places and
environments that can actually foster the
type of learning and play I want to talk about.
So, let me start by talking a little bit about
the strong beliefs, and it's more that beliefs
that actually--some of the lessons that I
learned in working, especially with Jean Piaget,
but then with other people on what learning
is about. So, the idea is that children may
not have much experience or knowledge, and
I mean experience in the sense of--in German
you have these beautiful distinctions that
don't exist in other languages--erfahrung
means experience as you are old and wise,
and erlebneiss is experience as being totally,
mindfully into situations. So, the children
may not have much experience in the sense
erfahrung or knowledge, but are sure born
with the knack to do the right thing in order
to find out about what they don't know yet.
This is an important point. One way of talking
about this, is to say they are experts in
self-directed learning, what ever that means.
I like to think of a child that is busy figuring
out their place in the world as a traveler
or newcomer to a foreign land that has to
convey their needs that have to be heard without
really speaking the language, without knowing
the habits, that have to plow along without
knowing the [unintelligible 8:05] very well,
deciding when to move on and when to settle,
deciding what to bring along and what to leave
behind, and deciding who to trust and not
to trust.
In a way, we have all had this experience
when we travel, I think. This is why people
like to travel, because it's like enacting
and re-experiencing these very fundamental
ways of handling uncertain situations. And
the point here is that is what impressive
with children is that it's not just that they
are very good at languages. We know that.
It's just the tip of the iceberg. It is that
they are incredible and we can learn a lot
from them in the way they maneuver and evolve
in a world that is by definition too complex,
uncertain, and unpredictable for them.
So, that's the starting point. I do like the
way in which Jean Piaget, who was my mentor,
and a Swiss developmental psychologist who
is quite well known. He has had a strong influence
in education, even if he didn't think of himself
as an educator. And that's another interesting
point.
He defined intelligence as adaptation. What
he said is that to adapt is not just to accommodate,
as we always think of it. It is not to change
ones views, or one's ways of being, or manners,
or even one's look just to conform to one's
surroundings. Like a chameleon who uses the
camouflage technique of changing color to
disappear in the background, or the character
of Zelligen in Budiiain's film, who always
tries to please whoever is around them, tries
to be loved and belong so strongly that he
has no spinal cord anymore. He's like a chameleon.
So, if you think of the ways in which people
adapt to their world, and especially young
people who are still very malleable because
they still have still a lot to learn, one
important aspect that sometimes gets underestimated
is that you also have to stay whole. You have
to withstand; you have to remain who you are.
You have to keep your identity, even if you
are constantly put into situations that require,
in a way, that you change your views.
What is very strong is this notion that to
adapt is not to control the uncontrollable
or to predict what is unpredictable. But it
is in a way this notion that you have to create
a niche in which it becomes possible to actually
live and evolve in ways that are pleasant
and agreeable to the person, organism that
we are considering.
The whole theory of Piaget that I am very
influenced by is built around this notion
of what it means to actually be fulfilled
personally, and also intellectually, and in
a way to succeed in the world. So, at the
beginning, the children are very fused with
their world. There are no distinctions between
themselves and the world. And as they grow,
there is this bifurcation. But they always
happen at the same time. It's like socialization,
individuation. Becoming an agent and becoming
in a way, able to relate to other people.
Attachment, detachment.
And as they grow older, and I will not focus
so much on that, the experiential field of
a person is expanding. They become able to
not just act in the here and now, but they
draw lessons from the past to project into
the future and vice-versa. And also the field,
as in the space, is expanding. People move
about as they grow older and expand their
field. Their maneuvering techniques and their
belief systems become more stable and more
mobile.
So, what the children--we know they are learning
everywhere, and all the time, in school, out
of school. They are learning through play
which leads grown-ups to say that play is
the child's more serious work. Now. what I
want to try to address is what does that mean,
what are the implications for anyone who is
interested in designing environments for young
people to actually grow, and live, and learn.
So, I will talk a little bit more about Jean
Piaget, then I will let go of him. He is mostly
known for his stages, developmental stages.
It is important because it provides a window
in what young people are interested in and
able to do, generally at different levels
or ages in their development.
There is more to Piaget than these stages,
and the part that interests me the most is
this notion that children have very coherent
and robust belief systems, and that their
belief systems are stubborn. They not easy
to shake, and this is so for very good adaptive
reasons. The whole theory shows that--it's
not to say that the children don't change
or are not influenced when they relate to
others, or when they interact with the world.
Their views are constantly evolving. But they
are evolving according to almost a logic of
their own.
When their belief system changes, it is jump-wise.
What this means is that it's not just because
you experience something at some time that
you are going to learn these pieces of knowledge.
You act in the world in different ways and
you begin to form a very structured belief
system. He calls it "structure," but it doesn't
matter. These pieces of knowledge are ways
of making sense of the world. They hang together.
They have co-dependencies between one another.
All this is to say that this has profound
implications for education. The first profound
implication for education of this view is
that teaching is always indirect. No matter
whether we like it or not as educators, teaching
is always indirect because people will always
interpret, assimilate what we tell them, teach
them, show them, the way we guide them into
situations according to their own belief systems,
experiences. They will re-translate it.
The more disturbing and important consequence
is that--Piaget used to say it in a very provocative
way--he said, "Whatever you teach to a learner,
you don't allow them to discover by themselves."
It's this notion of "Wait, wait, don't tell
me." When kids say, "Wait, wait, don't tell
me," it's "I want to discover it myself. I
need leads, I need offerings, but I want to
discover it by myself." And related is this
notion that any theory of learning that ignores
our present paying of attention to resistances
to learning or teaching in a way misses the
point.
Another important idea was developed more
by people I worked with later in my life,
so I've spent sort of half of my life trying
to understand how children's worldviews evolve
in different domains, mostly in the sciences
at the time. Then I started working when I
came to the US with designers, educators,
people who actually tried to design environments
for these kinds of learning to happen.
One of the important ideas, also from the
background working with Piaget and the whole
team, is that there are all these paradoxes.
If you actually want children to internalize
their action or to become a good thinker,
a good way of doing it is to let them externalize
what they think, because if you project out
or if you build something based on--or if
you re-enact something based on ideas that
you have, you're entering a dialogue with
your own expressions and enactments. And it
allows you to progress.
So, it's again a paradox, and there are many
examples. I don't have the time to go into
it, but if you are really interested in getting
kids to get the sense of what, for example,
numbers are about or understanding the concept
of numerosity, or number three, there are
plenty of ways that you can show embodiments
of that phenomenon in different contexts.
You contextualize them differently.
It's never just one, you see. It's not like
we're going to now talk about fractions, and
we are going to do the pi's. That doesn't
work. You need the whole array of possible
embodiments of the concept, and it's the learner
who makes the connections between when they
are ready, between these different contexts.
I now want to try to talk more about play.
I have spoken about learning too long. I like
to think of play as the art of world making,
and that play is about inventing invented
realities. It is about creating a world, physical
or virtual, inhabiting that world, and then
eventually becoming inhabited by it.
Now, sometimes you are invited into invented
realities that have been made or designed
by other people. I like to start with very
silly examples, like the entertainment park.
I think this is the word where the roller
coasters are. Imagine humanity has invented
for itself these crazy devices where people
actually go there to either take the driver's
seat and sort of experience the thrills of
things that if they did it in the real world,
it would be really dangerous. [laughter] Scary.
Or be taken for a ride, even, be taken for
a ride where you experience things in ways
that are just not so usual in real life.
In a way, I like to take the example of the
entertainment park because we are all thinking
that this is not where you play. But in a
way it is very interesting to think about
why humanity has invented these kinds of things.
The metaphor of leaping is often used. I have
a new material to leap, to capture the sense
of exuberance and freedom that characterizes
children's play this time, and I think it's
a good metaphor. People leap when they feel
like breaking loose or shaking off their habitual
ways of doing things, and of thinking. They
want to move out of their comfort zone.
So, we leap, for example, when we look at
things from different and surprising angles.
When we zoom in and out of a situation, as
like when you look at the drop of milk through
a microscope, or if you hover over Istanbul
and the south of France via Google Earth,
when you actually sit in an airplane and you
see the landscape becoming smaller. Each time
I am amazed by this.
We leap when we cross borders, when we transgress,
when we take a walk on the wild side, as Louis
was saying. And in our minds, we leap when
we mentally move between reelas that wouldn't
otherwise be juxtaposed in our everyday experience
that are unlikely, or when juxtaposing these
worlds, worlds that are not normally traversed.
You bring them together. So, that's a more
mental way of thinking about what leaping
is.
An example is when you move backwards and
forward in time which children always do in
pretend play. I am the baby. I am the poppa.
I am the momma. They like the Russian dolls
because it's a spatial version of it, almost.
The little one goes in the big one, and then
you put them in a row. All these games. It's
talking to our dolls, to imaginary companions.
It's a displacement pretense that all the
pretends play. Putting one's self in other
people's shoes. it's more role play.
Now, one can go a long way using the metaphor
of the leap to think about play, but I feel,
and this is a more personal add-on, I think
that the metaphor of the leap is important.
But what is equally important to think about
when we think about play is what I call the
"come back". It's a sense of sort of a settling
exhilaration that young children can feel
that emerge through enacting, in a way of
return.
So, the reason why this is important is that
you cannot leap without landing, or there
is no levity without gravity. So, as much
as kids love to move on--imagine a toddler,
the thrills of all of a sudden being able
to travel in the world and to have this whole
world turning around them while they move
on, they also like to come back.
The whole toy industry for young children
is built around this notion that, for example,
when a young child moves about in the world
and is disoriented, there is a reason to have
a pull along toy with you, because what it
does is that it gives you a sense that there
is something invariant. There is something
constant. It's your distance from it. It's
the fact that it follows you, and it creates
the sense almost of a very ephemeral home
for a little while, which is important.
The children play home. One of our colleagues,
Diane Willow, actually just put a tent inside
of the Children's Museum with light coming
from inside it. It's a beautiful exhibit because
it taps into children's desire to have tree
houses, their own little secret gardens and
so on.
There is another thing that is important.
It's the Hansel and Gretel aspect. It's nice
to wander into the forest. It's nice to go
wait for the moment of magic. It's nice to
go catch the butterflies, but it's also nice
to know that you can come back. And the whole
mythology of the labyrinth, of leaving a thread
behind, of leaving bread crumbs behind, is
an enactment of this desire to both move out,
transgress, walk on the wild side, and have
ways of coming back.
And as soon as the children learn to actually
talk and scribble at the same time--because
it's not that one appears before the other.
They are, again, it's a bifurcation. When
the children become two or three years of
age, they acquire what is called the symbolic
function. It has all these manifestations.
Learning to speak, playing with imaginary
companions, starting to pretend make- believe,
suspension of disbelief, first sense of humor,
and an incredible excitement when they can
leave places behind. When they write, and
when they walk, they become interested in
steps and I think those are very fundamental.
And they are played out constantly, when the
children are at play, and probably also when
grown-ups are at play. Why doesn't this one
move now? I had collected quite a few definitions
of play. but I am going to let them go. There
is one that is important. It's by Winnicott.
He talks about the importance of transitional
zones, and he talks about these objects that
very young children fall in love with, because
it in a way, it allows them again to navigate
the unknown. In this case, it's more relational.
It has to do with the mother that is not always
so good because every now and then she leaves,
[laughs] and to keep, in a way, this transitional
object. This blanket, or whatever the object
is, is a way of of actually saying, "I can
survive. I can survive this separation."
And they treat the transitional objects in
the way they think they are treated by the
person who cares about them. So, Winnicott
speaks beautifully about the fact that transitional
object has to be forgiving enough and resilient
enough to be loved, but also hated. [laughs]
To be treated in all kinds of ways. And John
Holt is an educator. He says that when children
play and use fantasies, it's not to get out,
but to get into the world. And this is an
important idea, because when we see, for example,
kids playing video games, and we spoke about
this at lunch, it is not that it's an escape.
If I read a book, it's not an escape from
reality. It gives me the possibility to actually
establish a dialogue between what is and what
could be. It allows me to invent different
narratives than the ones I am experiencing,
under certain sets of constraints, by changing
those sets of constraints, and embellishing,
or the opposite, or just giving, in a way,
the kind of weight and ending that
feel more desirable.
Now the play and creativity is another difficult
distinction to make, because it's not the
same in children in grown-ups, and it's not
necessarily the same in the sciences and in
the arts. And yet they have something in common.
Many people, in [unintelligible 31:10] in
particular, they talk about the fact that
creative individuals, scientists, artists,
or just plain folk usually make better use
of what is called lateral thinking. In a way,
it's like leaping. An ability to break lose
from acquired mental habits by looking at
a problem from different angles. Dobono has
been popularized in ways that are not interesting.
He himself was a deep thinker, [laughter]
and what he says is that lateral thinkers
tend to explore all of the different ways
of looking at something, rather than accepting
"This is important," the most promising and
proceeding from that. They do not assume that
old ideas should have precedence until something
better turns up. This is very Piaget. I mean,
as long as my world views are good enough,
I'm not going to change.
So, in a way, it's dominances. It's not that
they are in opposition, but they are people,
And I notice this with designers a lot, who
are more willing to play that game of not
taking for granted what actually has become
things they know or believe in. So, one way
of thinking about this is to say normally,
at least in scientists, the idea is driven
more by curiosity than playfulness. And those
seem a bit artificial to separate, but I think
it's a useful thing to do, at least for a
little moment. Curiosity is driven by the
urge to figure out how things work, to grasp
the logic of the patterns behind the surface
of things, to explain things away, sometimes
a bit too much. To debug, to prove, and they
have a clear, adaptive function: to turn the
unfamiliar into the familiar, the unknown
to the known. Playfulness is doing something
different. It's sort of driven by the desire
to imagine alternatives, which actually scientists
do a lot if they are innovative. Suspension
of disbelief is so important. The ability
to fictionalize, to dramatize reality, and
its adaptive function is likely different
of the one of getting to know. It's to turn
the familiar, or taken for granted, into the
uncanny, the humorous, the incongruous.
I am going to pass on this. This is the notion
that it's very important to let the objects
talk when you are actually in the process
of playing and also in the design process.
And children at play, or people who are playful
do that a lot. They let the objects talk to
help them. I am sorry, I am not being clear
on that. There are people who are always able
to solve problems in ways that allow them
to think less. And those are the real smart
ones. [laughter] My favorite example is Gaudi
when he was building the models from Sangra
de Familia. He realized that if he has some
threads hanging, and if he puts weights on
them, and if you imagine, you put this in
a liquid so you can freeze them, so to speak.
if you return them, you get the mathematics
of the arches in the other direction. And
in working with children, I constantly fall
upon children who are good at that. So if
you are asking a complicated question, like
there is this car driving around the lake,
and there is this person sitting driving.
He's on the side of the lake when the car
is on the other side where ... So you have
the kids that go like, "Mmm, mmm." They go
like this. In this case, it's not using the
object but your own body, instead of looking
at it from a God's eyes view and calculating
the reverse.
Or there are children--we were playing a game
of exchanging equal volumes of wood, but they
were cut in such a vicious way that you had
an equivalence between two blocks against
three. So, the question was the smallest property
common denominator of the smallest denominator.
So, the question is, how many blocks does
this person have to give to this person so
that they have the same amount of wood? You
have these kids that just start somewhere.
They align the blocks until they align themselves.
And then it's like, "OK." And then they go
in another direction until it aligns itself
and then guess what, they go in a third direction
and then they get that cube that is equal
to the other one.
Never they had counted. Never they had made
a multiplication. And I can multiply the examples
of working with young children on numbers
where they are incredible. They are able to
actually reconstruct same quantities elsewhere,
and it's not just perceptive. They would go,
"And there are three, and there are two, and
there is one, and there is five." So, they
use the ability to name small quantities perceptually.
They use music as a way to put them in a reason
to remember. It's like the glue between these
small chunks, and they use this whole thing
as a recipe to build equivalences at the other
end.
So, these to me are people who are more at
the end of coming up with creative solutions
that are clever, in the sense that they are
not based on this rational thinking and this
power of computation, but in the ability to
establish a dance, really, with the materials,
and to use so-called sensorimotor abilities
to help the world do half of the work for
you.
I think I should finish soon. The future of
play in education, I pass very quickly. The
problem with play in education--I call it
when the solution becomes the problem. I call
it, don't kill the play by adding the learning.
Play, by definition, cannot be co- modified,
and this is the difficulty. So, there is much
talk, especially these days, about measurable
gains, academic and professional, associated
with play and learning. The problem is to
me that the slow infusion of ever stronger
doses of serious message to play can actually,
at once, kill the play and hamper the learning.
In other words, the examples of canned play
are common in the field of education and also
of "edutainment." It's horrible, but when
you talk with educators who want to deliver
in more playful ways the contents of the particular
curriculum and you receive these boxes, it's
like Corn Flakes. Give it to your kids and
they will become smart. And it has actually
led to scandals with Mozart. Finally, people
became tired of this rhetoric, of selling
toys, also. I mean, I don't have to go into
detail more about that.
The future of play is the idea that today's
children don't always play, learn, or mingle
the way we expect them to, and what if they
did it in ritual ways that we don't always
see. There are a few areas of change that
are very clear, even if one doesn't want to
exaggerate the generational gaps. Today's
children are developing new ways of relating,
because their neighborhoods, their community
as we know them are no longer the same. So,
they invent other ways to keep relational
bonds beyond borders.
Their identities are also shifting, because
in a way, between private and public, the
boundaries are changing. Also, different ways
of moving between places and what you consider
home. There are many children who want, if
they have split families, they want either
to have the same toys in both homes, or they
carry Ninja Turtle bags that are always heavier
because they actually want to carry the thing
with them. And what they want is they become
fascinated with all the play that actually
allows them to glide between these places.
One important difference is also the relationship
to literacy. Because with the tools that we
have now, even if you think of writing, you
don't have the separation between writing
and reading anymore. It takes you an evening
to read the book and a year to write it. Now,
they meet in between, in what I call annotation,
because the reading becomes more and more
active, because you can cut and paste, you
can highlight, you can re-narrate whatever
you borrow and read, and you can also, when
you are on the writing side, you take these
chunks and you sort of pass them on more quick,
quicker. So, you have this circulation and
distribution of half-baked ideas that is very
characteristic of the way in which kids work
and that create incredible problems in education.
But the point that I want to make is that
all this is true. But maybe one of the most
interesting things is that the children today
are reclaiming their body and reclaiming a
sense of place. It's as if they have been
in the virtual world for a bit long, so now
you have the emergence of all these toys like
Wii, but you have also the children who actually
begin to re-enjoy, even if they go on the
web, they pay more attention to the context,
the physical context in which they do that.
So I have one slide here that is sort of the
manifest of the digital kid, what they would
like. It says, "Give me toys that I can carry
along. Give me toys that make me feel home
wherever I am. Give me toys that help me find
my ways and orient myself." So, this is besides
the leaping. "Give me building elements that
I won't lose." This is difficult. If you are
a builder on the go, Lego won't work because
you lose them. And to capture this notion,
it's like, "Make me able to explore and use
my creative skills locally, globally, anywhere,
anyyime but please don't forget, I do have
a body and I like to use it. I am exuberant,
I'm physical, so make me fly, transport me
and teleport me, but also make me touch, feel,
move, ground me."
I think I have to stop. I am going to pass,
because I had, of course, a whole part on
how you design environments for people to
actually be able to engage in play. One important
characteristic is that it's good if environments
or artifacts have holding power. This is the
notion that they just don't say, "Use you,"
wow, and then you get tired of them, but you
can revisit them constantly and it's actually
growing. "I grow with my toys and my toys
grow with me" is the idea here.
There are other qualities of these environments
that are important, that they allow you to
immerse yourself but then to come back. That
they are forgiving in the sense that nothing
kills. That's what's so useful in video games.
You can change perspective, you can change
the scale of things, you become a giant and
then you become a little ant. You can change
your stance in the world. The notion that
these spaces have always to be comfortable
in a way. They are often called third places.
They are neither like home nor like work.
They are more like stages, or cafes, or places
that you know when you come in that you can
behave differently. It's like, if I go to
a bar, I know I put my red lipstick and so
on. [laughter] Because it's a third place,
and I can stretch and explore aspects of myself
that I don't do if I am in a professional
meeting, with some corporate people or something
like this.
Another important thing, and I'm so happy
I heard about this here-- it's no segregation
by age. I had the chance to work for three
years in a European project which had the
ugly title of "Intergenerational Learning,"
but it's key, it's so important. And that's
what I like about museums. Because I am a
developmental psychologist, I am always asked,
when I work mostly with little kids, it's
like, "Is this developmentally correct, is
this the exact target group for this activity?"
And I'm going, "I am trying to do that well."
It's like when you are an architect it has
to function but then something else has to
happen.
So yes, they have to be targeted. But guess
what? They have to transcend. And in order
to transcend, they have to please people from
different backgrounds, walks of life, experience,
age, and they have to have an integrity that
actually engages people from different walks
of life.
So in a way, it's to think about places in
which people that otherwise wouldn't meet
come together to do things that they otherwise
wouldn't do. So, that's a nice definition
of the types of third places.
Last slide--if you think about the different
phases in a learning or in a play process,
sometimes we call it the five C's, it's like,
you have to connect, you have to be inspired,
it's a wow moment you psych up. And then to
think about the type of space, but not as
in a physical space that is dedicated, but
the kind of mental space that you need in
order to be inspired to connect it from. I
call it the imaginarium. If you are immersing
yourself hands-on, but also body immersion,
if you build, if you try out things, the idea
is more like the exploratorium. If you think
about things, contemplate, reflect, sometimes
they call it heads-in, which is an ugly term,
it's more like the sanctuary, because you
want, in a way, some quiet, in order to play
back. And that's what I spoke the whole evening,
it's that category, to play back things, to
re- visit, to recast, to give them form to
ideas, to dramatize, it's the stage. And share,
negotiate, collaborate, mingle, it's the piazza.
So, these are again, they are--wha-la, I am
done. Thank you.
I think nothing is harder than to give recommendations
that are specific enough for people who want
to design environments that are rich for play
and learning. So, I am only scratching the
surface, because the recommendations are much
too general. And even if you really start
really defining the qualities of these environments,
like they have to allow iteration, they have
to be forgiving, they have to be good enough
mothers, they have to be this, they have to
be that, it's always a little bit too general
and it doesn't quite help. I leave this for
discussion. Thank you. [applause]
Man 1: Thank you very much. We have a four
year old granddaughter and she likes to play
hide-and-go-seek and I was wondering, what's
the attraction, or the interest, what it is
it about hide-and-go-seek?
Edith: Yes, thank you for this question. [group
laughter] It's starts in babyhood with peek-a-boo.
It takes various forms. Hide-and-seek is one
form. It all has to do with enactments the
children enjoy and in which they play a very
active role to engage in to actually explore
this notion of permanency, object permanency.
When we talk about object permanancy, we don't
think just of objects, but of people. It starts
with very young children who love these games
of "I am here, I am not here, I'm here, I'm
not here," the little Debbie that comes out
of the box, oops, he comes up, he goes back,
it disappears, it comes back because young
children don't have object permanency. So,
when the ball disappears behind the sofa,
it's gone. No problem, no attachment. I'm
happy; I'm seduced by the next thing that
comes my way.
Around the age of eight months, they begin
to be shy of strangers precisely, because
there is memory of something that has gone.
It starts developing. And all the games of
hide-and-seek and so on are different versions
for people of different ages to play out as
in theater. This coming and going of things,
again it's the absence and the presence, the
leap, and I come back.
The hide-and-seek is a little bit particular,
because little kids don't understand what
they need to do to be really hidden from somebody
else. It's another very interesting thing
that gets enacted. It's about learning to
take on perspectives, to understand what's
in the mind of somebody else who's not in
your position. You see? It's one way of actually
enacting these kinds of permanence about.
But when they are little, they don't get it.
I don't know about your four year old. I don't
know about how she plays hide-and -seek.
Man 1: She hides in trees, she hides in the
closet.
Edith: OK, that's pretty good. [laughter]
It's hard to interpret, but this can almost
be an enactment of "I know you're going to
find me again." Because there is always this
double joy and pleasure about "I want to go,
I want to be autonomous, I want separation,
I want to be Ulysses, I want to be the traveler,
I want not to be attached, but at the same
time I want to be attached, I want to be pent
up, I want to come back, I want to be comforted."
And these are very difficult balances to achieve,
and it's at the heart and core of what it
means to grow as a person, at a personal level
as well as at the cognitive level, or relational
level.
These are almost archetypes, and I think that
in the types of obsessions, that the digital
natives people today engage in have even more
to do with that because they are sometimes
unwillingly living lives where they constantly
move between worlds. They are more like nomads.
And what do the nomads do? They always come
back. They have this ritual of coming back.
So you have many, many examples in a way of
kids. The way I imagine this mythology is
again about, "I am going; you don't know where
I am. but I am having fun and I am capturing
things in the environment." It can be with
your cell phone. It's like photographing what
you eat, you know. "I am going, but I keep
track, I keep trace," it's not even leaving
a mark but I keep track.
And then at night, what do I do? I contact
my friends to show them what I have been doing
because that is as important.
So in a way, you can all of a sudden shed
light. Some of the technologies that they
like to carry around or the things that they
like to do through this lens, because you
begin to realize that they love to share their
captures. They save them for later and then
they love to share them on common. Even if
it's online, it allows them to play these
games of "I go, I come back." It's a long
answer to hide and seek but...
[laughter]
Woman 1: You were speaking about all the elements,
in a public space of inspiring kids to be
hands on and to immerse themselves. But, now
we have a society in a lot of public spaces
where everybody has hand sanitizer. [laughter]
Edith: Yes.
Woman 1: And they don't want kids to touch
anything. I work in a hospital so...
Edith: Yes.
Woman 1: That challenge of inspire...
Edith: I know.
Woman 1: ...get the kids to move, be a part
of something, but don't touch it really. Could
you comment on that?
Edith: I have no good answer. I only have
hopes that I see symptoms of
new rituals around that we see that go counter
this tendency. And the example I have in mind
is the maker's fair. It's a very strange phenomenon
where all of a sudden, you have all these
people who have lived online, who have created
their own second lives and all these things.
They come together, like, to go to Woodstock
you know? In tribes. And what do they do?
They bring stuff and they show it to one another
and it has to be in a physical place and some
people like it, some people don't. Some people
think its not really arts, it's not a novelty.
But I cannot answer your question. I can just
try to become attentive while this trend is
certainly very strong of creative ways in
which younger people actually deal with these
kinds of challenges. And one of them was also
that there was an incredible resilience at
a certain point on the part of the geeks,
the ones that live constantly in the virtual
world, to actually establish rapport with
other people that are not physical.
They were very close, but it was not necessarily
physically close. And I don't know what this
does. On the other hand, you have these ways
in which people come together, also in hybrid
ways that are very interesting.
It's not just only online. And I become myself
more and more interested in studying, not
just when you look at kids or young people
staring at the computer screen and entering
their world, it's interesting to look at how
they actually go in each other's houses.
There are lots of rituals around this that
go beyond just what they stare at. They like
to slouch on couches, they have their own
way of keeping a physical rapport with the
place and other people, even if they go away
ever now and then. It's like when we have
our cell phones, we're still here.
I think the only way to go about this is to
study these hybrids where physical, virtual,
and digital merge in interesting and unusual
ways. That's all I can say.
It's very difficult, too. But I agree, I arrived
yesterday in Minneapolis at three o'clock,
and I am in the at the center of the city.
The financial center, I guess. And my question
was "Donde esta la gente? Where are the people
here?" [laughter]
You have these streets that are totally empty,
you have these gorgeous huge buildings, the
windows of which you cannot open most of the
time. It is a striking shock when you arrive.
But I am an optimist, because I think that
people are very smart in inventing for themselves
places, and environments, and rituals that
are made for that.
I come from Europe and I was an intellectual
in the 60's, and the cafe was sacred, and
so on. But I enjoy when I see the all the
geeks working at their own computer in the
cyber cafe.
It's not the same, but it's a funny way that
they have to come together without talking
to one another. [laughter]
Now they start doing things together. They
communicate a lot through what they are doing,
which is also can lead to some--and they jump.
What is also very nice is that at the Exploratorium--I
don't know if you were there, Keith--at the
Exploratorium. They did a whole activity around
sound. There was actually one session where
very known artists, sound artists, came to
talk about their work. And it was very nice
to see the kinds of questions from the young
makers. They had no sense of hierarchy, they
had no sense of comparing their production
with the production of Walter Ketundu or other
wonderful artists who work with sound.
The questions were all technical. "How do
you get this sound to come out from these
tubes?" The questions were all technical.
And I found this very interesting because
it's as if they were in this world of hobbyists,
of makers that work together and the question
is, "How to optimize what I am really interested
in doing?" So, they are very refreshing in
the questions they ask, because it's not like
the usual shyness, you know in front of the
big artist.
I don't know what it entails in terms of the
quality of their work. It's not enough to
just throw out something and then it's enough.
And when I have organized workshops for kids'
designers, kids' play, kids' technology, more
than you ever want to participate in any more
and usually they stop when every kid comes
with a little contraption they have built.
It's more or less cute or not. You can say,
"Yeah, it's great."
But you never have the time to come back and
then actually either really respect the work
by re-choreographing it in different ways
or imagining games like, the children come
back with what they have produced and you
go for a second round, saying for example,
"Take whichever inspires you best, even if
it's not your own and continue to work on
it as if it were your own." And you go through
alterations, and there has to be way to allow
these productions to become better crafted,
to become more polished and also to become
something that is bigger than just my own
little first attempt at sketching something.
This is very important, but it's easier said
than done.
Man 2: I have a question for you. You've been
talking about the internal, technical inside
space lifestyles of children. And in this
country, we're becoming more urbanized. What
do you perceive are changes taking place in
how families raise their children in more
urban environments versus say forty years
ago...
Edith: Yes.
Man 2: ...when it was more suburban and rural?
Edith: Yes. That's a whole other, very complicated
question. [laughter] I like to almost start
from the point of view of the child, thinking
sort of what's in their mind, what's on their
plate and what's in their toy chests, you
know? And from the point of view of the child,
oftentimes they have single parents or they
have split family situations. They also have
situations where parents get remarried after
having had children so there are many kids
around, like it's this tribe of kids. So,
I always like to think that the kids are thinking,
"I love to go out with my family, but can
you tell me who is part of my family?" [laughter]
And in a way, they have their own way of--because
it's not so clear sometimes--they have their
own way of reinventing the family in terms
of the kinds of people that they want around
themselves to feel good. Those are all the
examples. We worked a lot on this one at Lego
to try to understand how they respond to these
situations precisely.
For example, if you live in one apartment
in town, at some point in another, the kids
are very different. Either they like to have
duplicates, to feel at home almost anywhere
which is not really home.
It's like in America, when you travel. I think
Americans are a nomadic tribe without them
realizing it because they came to this country
and they were more pioneers. So, this nice
thing--it's not just the mobile home, it's
the thing that you find wherever you go. It
can be the McDonald's. When you go to a park,
it's that particular bench.
So, when people come, in a way, it is the
same because it's a duplicate of it. So, if
a child travels with their parent and each
time when you stop you find those benches,
it's OK and you eat your McDonald's. It's
OK. It's not too disturbing.
So, that's for the part of being comforted.
It's the notion of the carpet that the nomadic
people carry with them, and that is the most
precious object because wherever they go they
stake their territory, they sit on it, and
they are home.
And there are all these nice studies that
are done also, by artists, about how people
inhabit spaces that they know they cannot
stay long in, like hotels, or how they relate
to their luggage, to their objects in luggage.
Again, there are very different strategies.
There are those who, no matter where they
are in the hotel, how horrible or beautiful,
they always have to put a few objects in a
very particular place to stake their territory
and feel at home.
Others don't care. They put themselves in
a bubble. The only thing they want is the
plug to put on their computer, because that's
home. I go through my email, I am comforted.
And a shower should be good, and the bed should
be good. They stay in a bubble and that's
what they bring with themselves.
The children do that a lot, for example, in
the world of toys. I've worked for Lego for
so long. At the beginning it was all about
bricks but you can't carry bricks along, so
if you have different places where you go
to, you just need your stack of bricks. If
children travel, what they like is to bring
little micro-worlds with themselves, the little
mini-worlds where you can do things, or the
video games because they come with you.
I understand that they like to bring their
little--I like to bring my computer with me
now when I travel because again, it's a way
of settling. It's about settling even if you
know that the places in which you settle are
totally not permanent and fragile.
Man 3: You talked about perspective in play.
Can you talk a little bit about, especially
for the digital natives, about watching themselves
play, that phenomena of them being on camera
or them seeing themselves?
Edith: Can you say a bit more what they do?
Man 3: Sure. Well, it came mostly from another
generation of the MTV generation, where they
watched themselves dance or do things, and
their behavior changed. Now, with some of
these digital natives, with virtual cam, webcam,
they're watching themselves behave in a way
and they're changing. And also Skype. They're
watching themselves change how they play.
Edith: Yes, this is wonderful, because it
is almost a technique to allow to modify as
you go along the narrative, and also the way
in which you want to portray yourself, because
it keeps track of what you are doing in a
way that you cannot appreciate if you are
really in the actions. So, it's a way of actually
having these mirrors. Mirrors have been important,
like in the elementary school system for young
children, they use mirrors a lot, and all
kinds of mirrors. They have, for example,
these triangular mirrors where people go in;
they have all kinds of mirrors, and maybe
it's a way to keep track and to be able to
operate these desired changes in their own
appearance, identity, to play around to explore
that. I don't quite know. What strikes me
also is all these versions of karaoke. I don't
know what this about. [laughter] I am sure
you have better insights than I do on this
question. [laughter]
Man 4: Why do we like Legos so much?
Edith: My goodness. OK. This has to do, I
think, with I said at some point that one
quality of the environment can be "I grow
with my toys, my toys grow with me." And they
are very constrained, and I think they have
affordances that don't please everybody. So,
what they are good at is, some people call
it, "low-floor, high-ceiling." You enter,
you begin to use your hands, even if you have
no ideas, you build something and it gives
you an idea. And then you change it, and it
gives you an idea. So, it's this notion that
you start by meddling around, even if you
have no ideas, and it's delightful to see
that as you go along, you see things that
are surprising, and it makes you have better
ideas, and you go on, and you sharpen it.
It's not like solving a problem that has one
definite solution. So, that's one thing that
I think we like. What we like is the modular
quality of the environment. You know somehow
that there are many different ways of connecting
things, and that it will always work, because
the system is modular, even if it's very constrained.
I think also that the rapport itself has become
rich enough that you can move beyond just
building towers and orthogonal structures.
You can start doing other things. If you add
motors or sensors, you can start doing interesting
things.
What I think Lego does not address is the
"wide walls" aspect. When people talk about
"low-floor, high-ceiling, " there is this
notion of "wide walls." It attracts many different
types of people, because it is very layered,
and it is very rich in the sense that it speaks
to many people. And I think Lego, in a way,
speaks to boys. It wants to speak to boys.
It doesn't mean that many girls are not interested
in it, but they have been working along this
path of just developing these wonderful elements
to build these organized structures.
But what you see in workshops is that there
are some people who are more attracted to
using--let's say, even a contraption that
does something, like a robot or a conveyor
belt or some mechanical device.
They come from a world in which they like
more--I call it an organic rather than mechanical
metaphors--that they live by. And they like
to create little creatures that will sense
if there is no more water in the Earth for
the plant and that will just water the plant.
Or some device that does something in the
environment, but it's not you that control
it or it controls something else, in very
mechanical terms.
So, in a way, Lego, I think, they have tried.
They actually, at some point, they were working
on a very interesting system--what was it
called? I forgot the name--where you could
do jewelry in these modular ways.
And they had watches where you could do them
in a modular way. Snap it or it had a word
like this. Snap it together. They were wonderful.
They were like plexi-wires, and you had these
elements that you could click on it so you
could do colors, you could do earrings.
But you could also, if you are a little boy,
you could do accessories. You could do decoration
because you could attach them on other objects
in the environment. They had a wonderful quality,
but they never made it because I think the
culture, itself, is growing around the brick.
And it's the brick.
[laughter]
Woman 2: It was mentioned that you have had
some influence from Maria Montessori and I'm
just wondering if--as a Montessorian, it's
always interesting to hear what parts people
are attracted to and I can imagine certain
things, but I'm just wondering if you can
expand on that a bit.
Edith: Yeah, there are two things that Madame
Montessori did very well. I think it's this
notion that if you actually want to open space
in the children's minds, their environment
has to be pretty well organized. It's this
paradox that a space, especially for little
children, they have to know where the materials
are, where they can find them, to actually
help them understand that they could use them.
If everything is messy around, if there is
absolutely no clarity in what could be found
where, it makes it more difficult to be creative.
It's a paradoxical idea.
And from my readings of the text of Maria
Montessori is that--and this comes through
very much in the original Emelia infant toddler
schools. It is very organized, but not as
in a military way, in a very gentle way.
And the children are invited to the rituals
of bringing the things back. And we can play,
we open it up, but we bring them back so that
everybody knows where things are.
That's one thing and the other one is just--many
of these materials have the quality of the
Froebel gifts. They are extraordinary embodiments
of aspects of a phenomenon that you can play
with. But then again, the danger is if somebody
who is not very knowledgeable about the fact
that if you want children to understand a
phenomenon you can have too various of those
embodiments. Maybe it can become too rigid.
I don't know.
But for example, the Montessori bells. You
could imagine very different ways in which
you can give a child a sense of music, and
the Montessori bells are just one possible
embodiment of aspects of the phenomenon. Then
you can have games where, for example, you
play with the synesthesia between movement
and sound. You could have just playing an
instrument. You could have building reason
machines.
Probably she was very good at this. I don't
know enough about Montessori because it's
not really from within. I have never really
worked in Montessori school, but the art is
really to imagine these different ways in
which you can unfold the phenomenon, because
otherwise embodiments are not good enough.
You see, it makes me sad and sick when I hear
now there is this incredible fad among academics.
Everything has to be embodied. Embodied cognition.
And it is nothing else than--I call it in
my own academic term--it's a return of a certain
kind of empiricism. It's like, "Play with
this thing. Play with these cakes and you
will understand fractions." Or, "Play with
these materials." Because the idea is that
the concept is embodied in the materials,
which is never the case.
But I think the Montessori materials, especially
the way they are used in Montessori schools,
do that very well. The third thing I like
about her is that the senses are important
to her, maybe more than to Piaget, because
he was more interested in the child as a young
scientist and was more heady.
So, the materials that they came up with,
this game-like situation in which you invite
the kids to play, they are also kind of nice
but not as nice. He doesn't pay attention
to the senses so much, which Madame Montessori
does. I don't know if there are still aspects
that you think of that I let aside that you
enjoy.
Woman 2: Well it was interesting to hear you
talk about the child as the foreigner. She
had thought that it was important for the
child to have a heavy dose of realism in her
stages of development. The realism comes first,
and the imagination later. As a teacher I
always have trouble talking with parents about
that. They get very upset about me poo-pooing
Winnie the Pooh, for instance, at least the
Disney version anyway. When in fact, what
the children in the Montessori tradition are
needing is practical life skills. You talked
about the sensorial materials that Maria Montessori
created for her environments. That's an important
difference between, say something like Waldorf.
Edith: Yes, I think that they solve it very
well. If I think of the schools of Reggio,
Reggio Emilia--they have this incredible,
beautiful way of working with very young children.
You can almost think of it as--if Madame Montessori
was still there she would be in that school
where many artists work with children like
Bruno Monari, or people who work on children
and poetry and it's very rich. And in a way
it's true. They would say things like "we
are what we eat" and the children have to
behave in a way, they have these lovely kitchen
and you see the kids, they are not completely
crazy. And they have these places where they
actually play games like going to the store,
where they do these things. But at the same
time they also do these completely different
types of things. They crawl through mirrors,
they do things like this, but they also do
these installations. The kids do installations.
So, for example they used the overhead projector
to project things and when you see the children
play, it's the same. I think us adults, we
have poor ways of establishing distinction
between realities and fiction. It was a constant
discussion at Lego. And I think it's a better
way to think of the fact that every reality
is an invented reality, and sometimes you
need to play out things that seem very mundane.
It's nice to do the dishes when mom does the
dishes, but sometimes it's also about something
else, you know? Sometimes it's about hide-and-seek,
because there are not just these pragmatic
things that make us who we are, it's also
the fears that we have, the way we see ourselves,
the way we relate to other people and they
are traditions and groupings. Play types are
all about that.
So, my suggestion would be to try to break
this distinction the way we usually do it,
between things that are more realistic and
things that are more imaginary. Or even in
kids' drawings, the realistic phase in the
kids' drawing actually comes later, because
when they are little they draw what they know,
what they imagine, and then it becomes more
realistic.
I don't know, but I myself find it useful
to abandon these dichotomies. Because you
have too many people who say, "The kids from
inner city, they cannot pretend--for them
it has to be very pragmatic. The girls, the
girls are more like realistic and the boys..."
I did lot of studies of young children's pretense.
And the fundamentals are less about that than
how they engage with play.
So, I did notice something, it's neither the
girls are controlling when they are in the
kitchen and the boys when it is outside or
the girls play more realistic. It's more about,
for the girls, it's like they choreograph.
So they are like a giant and they have this
little thing, "This one talks to this one,
and this one talks to this one." In a way,
they take on a God's eye view and everybody
always says the girls are more immersed.
The boys go, "Bvvvvvvvv, " [laughter] so it's
like their body almost becomes the airplane
and so on. So, I don't know if it's a boy/girl
thing and I would not want to have me quoted
on it, but there are these different ways
in which people--and again, it shifts because
the ones that at some moment are the choreographers
then they dwell in, because they project themselves
in the character, they make it grow, they
speak from the point of view of the character
and no longer just organizing. And it's very
difficult to talk about reality or fiction
in that way because sometimes, I don't know,
reality is the strangest of all fictions sometimes.
[laughter]
Woman 2: Thank you very much. [applause]
Edith: Thank you.